Que va-t'il se passer sur cette chaine
Les gens se le demandent voilà
On m'arrête dans la rue, les journalistes m'arrêtent...
les gens se réunissent en secret pour élaborer des théories du complot
Suis-je Roumain ?
Suis-je Reptilien ?
Voilà. Tout le monde en parle  y'en a marre... Maintenant je vais répondre à la question qui est...
Que va-t'il se passer cette chaine ?
Eh oui un petit peu quels sont les prochains projets
Je ne peux pas tout vous dire parce qu'il y a des petits secrets encore
N'est-ce pas théories du complot, reptiliens.. Je viens d'une autre planète
On va commencer avec le plus gros projet là, qui va arriver pas pour tout de suite
Mais plutôt pour la rentrée
C'est mon prochain court-métrage... Le voici le voila c'est vingt pages d'une nouvelle aventure
C'est pas pour tout de suite parce que y'a pas mal de préparation...
Le casting, les décors, préparer l'équipe... y va y avoir pas mal de journées de tournage
J'espère que ça va vous plaire
C'est assez différent de "Lunaire"...
C'est assez différent de "Dessine moi un Alien"
J'ai envie d'essayer des nouvelles histoires... C'est un peu plus sérieux.
J'expérimente... J'expérimente parce que je suis un reptilien
Voilà, je ne vois que cette explication.
Vous l'avez peut-être remarqué mais derrière moi il y a un nouveau studio.
Voilà c'est le studio de ma chaine gaming avec Squeezie
Et en fait on a pris le nom, ON L'A EXPLOSÉ !!! Comme ça...
Et ça s'appelle désormais Bigorneaux et Coquillages
Pourquoi ? Je ne saurais l'expliquer tout est parti très vite en couille...
Le nom c'est ça, y faudra s'habituer
Puis je sais pas pourquoi...
Putain on aime même pas spécialement les fruits de mers... Je sais pas pourquoi ça s'appelle comme ça
Et bien sûr on reprend cette chaîne avec des sortes de petits défis, des vlogs
On essaye des véhicules.. enfin on fait tout et n'importe quoi
C'est chaque semaines donc n'hésitez pas à vous abonner si c'est pas déjà fait.
Je fais ça mais je sais pas si ça sera cliquable. Peut-être dans le... Dans la description voilà vous pourrez cliquer sur "Bigorneaux et Coquillages"
Et enfin il y a le retour d'un très gros projet
Ça fait depuis le début de l'année que je bosse dessus
C'est le retour de ma série audio de l'été...
"L'Épopée Temporelle"
J'ai reçu beaucoup de messages de gens qui voulaient la suite
Ça m'a fait extrêmement plaisir...
La nouvelle saison de "L'Épopée Temporelle" revient
J'ai eu aussi des messages, qui m'ont fait très plaisir, où en fait les gens avouaient que la série audio c'était pas trop leur délire
Ils me disaient: Mais en fait sans images, je vois pas pourquoi je vais écouter ce truc là...
Et finalement, j'ai écouté 1 ou 2 épisodes et j'ai tout écouté, et je veux savoir la suite...
Et donc voilà, ce genre de messages ça me fait très plaisir
Merci à vous les gars de croire en ce que je fais même si ça peut être un peu étrange
Au premier abord comme ça donc euh... j'vous aime
J'ai aussi reçu des messages: arrête avec tes histoires et tes courts métrages,
Je préfère les podcasts sur "l'école..."
Voilà ça c'est, c'est... c'est ma vie voilà, c'est ma vie ! Aujourd'hui euh... ce genre de messages, Merci beaucoup les gars !
C'était un kiff énorme de faire la première saison l'année dernière qui a fait plus de 20 millions de vues, c'est incroyable...
Donc c'est normal finalement qu'on fasse la suite, qui reviens dès jeudi, dès après-demain
Sur ma chaîne Youtube toute les semaines, cet été...
Alors dans cette nouvelle saison, les épisodes sont plus longs, y va y avoir des "guests" aussi du genre Antoine Daniel, François Damiens...
Y va y avoir de nouvelles musiques composées, des nouveaux personages, une nouvelle intrigue,...
Des nouvelles illustrations... On a enregistrer pendant 10 jours avec une vingtaine de comédiens...
C'était mortel. Vous pouvez écouter la nouvelle saison sans forcément avoir écouter la première. Voilà y'a pas de problèmes
Vous pouvez comprendre l'histoire mais c'est quand même un peut plus kiffant et puis les épisodes sont gratuits sur ma chaîne Youtube
Vous pouvez dès à présent... C'est parfait pour l'été, avec les petits écouteurs comme ça ou au travail, si vous faites semblant de travailler
Et vous pouvez regarder aussi les illustrations sur la chaîne Youtube
Avec des illustrateurs qui sont comme ça, c'est à dire qu'on mange les illustrateurs
Mmm très très bon celui-là, mmm
Je suis très fier du résultat donc j'espère que ça va vous plaire. J'ai hâte que ça sorte
Et enfin y'a pas mal d'autres projets qui sont en préparation, sketchs, podcasts et des trucs qui sont en dehors de ma chaîne YouTube
Mais j'peux pas trop vous en parler. Gros suspens, de bâtard. JE VOUS CACHE DES CHOSES, THÉORIES DU COMPLOT !!
Pour résumer c'est le retour de ma chaîne secondaire "Cyprien Gaming " qui s'appelle désormais "Bigorneaux et Coquillages"
Et aussi un épisode par semaine sur ma chaîne YouTube de "L'Épopée Temporelle", ma série audio de l'été...
Et d'autres projets un petit peu mystérieux et notamment un court-métrage qui va arriver à la rentrée
Bisous !
Abonne-toi !
Sous-titres édités par Silwynn.